[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta
Slomka guten Abend auch heute gingen
wieder ztausende gegen Rechtsextremismus
auf die Straße mehr als
150000 in Berlin aber auch in vielen
anderen großen und kleinen Städten und
Landkreisen gab es zahlreiche
Demonstrationen weitere sind für morgen
geplant und dabei gilt je kleiner der
Ort je stärker dort rechtsradikale
vertreten sind desto bemerkenswerter ist
diese Form des Gesicht Zeigens bislang
scheint der Antrieb das zu tun mit
möglichst vielen gemeinsam nicht
nachzulassen Roman leskowa berichtet aus
Berlin Hand die Menschenmenge vor dem
Berliner Reichstag eine symbolische
Brandmauer Teil des Protestes heute sie
wollen das Hohe Haus der Demokratie
schützen vor Angriffen von Rechtsaußen
aufgerufen hatte ein breites
zivilgesellschaftliches
Bündnis wir sind knapp 2000
Organisationen
und wir sind hier um klares Zeichen
gegen Recht zu setzen aber halt eben
auch um die Politik und die
demokratischen Parteien die
Verantwortung zu ziehen den Rechtsruck
zu bekämpfen und die Ursach
gekommen waren erneut junge und ältere
Familien und Menschen die sich von den
bekannt gewordenen Migranten
vertreibungsfantasien der extremen
Rechten direkt angesprochen
fühlenesalderin etwa die mit einer
Freundin hier ist macht das Angst die
gebürtige Hamburgerin mit kurdischen
Wurzeln ist Ärztin in einem Berliner
Krankenhaus die kruden Ideen
verunsicherten obwohl sie für Sieger
keinen Sinn mach wir werden gebraut alle
Ärzte unabhängig von ihrer Herkunft
werden gebraut oder Pflegekräfte und ich
find deshalb unglaublich dass halt
solche Gedanken im Raum geworfen werden
oder päne geschmedet werden es dürfte
die bislang größte Kundgebung der
vergangenen dre Wochen gewesen sein von
150.000 Teilnehmern spricht die Polizei
die Organisatoren gehen von doppelt so
viel aus aktuell sinken die Umfragewerte
der AFD leicht ob die Proteste dafür
verantwortlich sind darüber gehen die
Meinungen auseinander es könnte sein
dass wenn viele auf die Straße gehen
auch man noch mal über seine eigene
Position nachdenkt ich glaube es es
kommt bei den Menschen an was die AFD
anrichtet was was für eine Gefahr von
der AFD ausgeht das bekommen die Leute
mit und deswegen sind auch paar
Prozentpunkte zurückgegangen ich finde
schon dass da ein Zusammenhang ist weil
vor allen Dingen die Menschen die als
Protestwähler die AFD
wählen jetzt merken dass das kein
Prozess ist sonder Protest ist sondern
einfach der falsche Weg ich glaube die
Demonstrationen sind einfach gut um auch
der aktuellen den aktuellen Politiker in
zu zeigen was in der Bevölkerung für
eine Stimmung herrscht und das einfach
politisch da auch was getan werden muss
immer wieder war heute auch der Wunsch
zu hören dass die Proteste länger
nachhallen am besten über die
anstehenden Wahlen hinaus und dass die
Brandmauer hält nicht nur symbolisch vor
sondern auch in den Parlamenten im
Land die AFD erklärt diese Massendemos
als gegen sie gerichtete
Hetzkampagne zugleich hofft AFD Chef
krupalla dass sich dadurch mehr Menschen
mit der Programmatik seiner Partei
beschäftigen WD
das könnte durchaus sein so interessiert
sich aktuell nicht nur der
brandenburgische Verfassungsschutz für
die Äußerung eines AFD
Landtagsabgeordneten der kürzlich
angekündigt hatte dass die AFD den
Parteienstaat abschaffen
müsse das hatten einst auch die
Antidemokraten in der weimmarer Republik
gefordert und die Nationalsozialisten
der verhasste Parteienstaat musste weg
um das Gegenmodell den Führerstaat
errichten zu können Albrecht
berichtet seit 2020 beobachtet der
Verfassungsschutz die AFD Brandenburg
als rechtsextremistischen Verdachtsfall
diese Einstufung soll nun noch einmal
überprüft werden Anlass einer Aussage
des AFD Landtagsabgeordneten Lars Hünig
auf diesem Bürgerdialog am 18 januar in
Falkensee dort schimpft er zunächst auf
angeblich korrupte Politiker und
Parteien und verspricht seinen Zuhörern
schließlich wenn wir morgen in einer
Regierungsverantwortung sind müssen wir
diesen Parteienstaat abschaffen den
Parteienstaat abschaffen diese Aussage
sorgt für Empörung und Diskussion im
Innenausschuss des Brandenburger
Landtags verfassungsschutzchef Müller
zeigt sich alarmiert er hat ein direkten
Angriff auf die parlamentarische
Demokratie gestartet indem er sagt wir
schaffen diesen Parteienstaat ab und
verstößt damit gegen Artikel 21
Grundgesetz das Parteienprivileg dort
steht eben drin dass die Parteien am
politischen
Meinungsbildungsprozess des Volkes
mitwirken und dagegen verstößt der an
die AFD sieht sich unterdessen als Opfer
einer Hetzkampagne sie würde böswillig
missverstanden gemein sein mit
parteienstat der Umstand dass sich die
Parteien den Staat zur Beute gemacht
hätten woraufhin Hünig selbst seine
Aussage diesen abschaffen zu wollen noch
einmal auf Ex bekräftigt absolut der
brandenburgische Innenminister stübkgen
sieeh darin gab Parallelen zur NS
Diktatur Zitat mit dem Kampfbegriff
Parteienstaat wurde schon einmal die
parlamentarische Demokratie ab geschafft
das war 1933 und Politikwissenschaftler
sind sich einig die vielfältige
Parteienlandschaft ist Grundpfeiler der
pluralistischen
Demokratie es ist sicherlich nicht so
dass man nicht Kritik an Parteien üben
darf oder an bestimmten Entscheidungen
die gefällt werden es ist etwas
qualitativ völlig anderes die
Abschaffung des parteienstaats mit dem
Wort Parteienstaat insbesondere zu
fordern nun will der Verfassungsschutz
die Aussage hü in die Bewertung
einfließen lassen ob die Partei künftig
als gesichert rechtsextremistisch
eingestuft werden
soll und dann blicken wir ins Ausland im
Weißen Haus raucht man sich
wahrscheinlich seit Wochen die Haare
weitere Eskalationen im Nahen Osten sind
das letzte was der US-Präsident im
Wahlkampf gebrauchen kann doch zuletzt
passierte ja praktisch jeden Tag etwas
Neues mal greifen die jemenitischen hui
Schiffe im Roten Meer an mal attackieren
Milizen mit Verbindungen zum Iran
amerikanische Militäreinrichtungen in
der Region als dabei letzten Sonntag
drei US-Soldaten starben war klar dass
es eine Reaktion geben würde und die
folgte gestern Abend wie diese
Militärschläge heute bewertet werden
berichtet ein gezielter Luftschlag löst
eine Reihe von Explosionen
aus Raketen machen sich selbständig ganz
offenbar wurde inim im Irak Waffen und
Munitionslager getroffen das Ziel lag
mitten in einer Wohnstraße aber die
Anwohner bestätigen dass eine Miliz ihr
Versteck in diesem Haus hatte ein
Zivilist starb ihr Ärger richtet sich
gegen die irakische Regierung sie soll
dafür sorgen dass das Militär aus
unseren Wohnvierteln verschwindet sagt
er amerikanische B1 Bomber waren in
Texas gestartet ein Signal dass die USA
jeden beliebigen Ort in der Welt treffen
könnten auch in Iran die Ziele jetzt
lagen in Irak und Syrien auch
Stützpunkte der kotzeinheit der
Elitetruppe der iranischen
revolutionsgarten Irans Innenminister
verurteilt die Angriffe sie würden die
Flammen des Widerstands anfachen man
müsse Weise handeln anders als die
Amerikaner es ist Vergeltung für die bei
einem Drohnenangriff getöteten
US-Soldaten aber auch Abschreckung gegen
Iran und seine Helfer eine Gradwanderung
für den Präsidenten die USA so ließ er
wissen wollten ke einen Krieg aber wer
ihnen schade bekomme eine Antwort und
das sei nur der
Auftakt wir wollen keine Ausweitung
keinen
Regionalkonflikt keinen Krieg mit Iran
aber wir ziehen jene zur Verantwortung
die unsere Truppen von Irak und Syrien
aus angreifen beiden gerade im Wahlkampf
hat weitere Luftschläge befohlen sie
sollen künftige Attacken auf US-Truppen
unmöglich machen parallel so heißt es
fordere Washington über einen
backchannel einen indirekten Kontakt vom
Regime in Terran die Milizen zu stoppen
gelingt das nicht liegen im Pentagon
Pläne für direkte Schläge gegen den Iran
bereit auch letzte Nacht mussten US
Kampfjets über dem Roten Meer einmal
mehr Drohnenangriffe von der Iran nahan
huti Miliz
abwähren und einen großen unfassbar
zerstörerischen Landkrieg in Europa
haben wir ja auch noch seit dem russland
versucht die Ukraine zu unterwerfen das
gelingt zwar nicht aber für die Ukrainer
läuft es auch nicht gut es fehlt an
Waffen um sich militärstrategisch neu
aufzustellen es gibt Spannungen zwischen
selenski und seinem obersten general und
Erschöpfung in der Bevölkerung und
trotzdem weiterhin eine große
Entschlossenheit unsere reporterin Anne
Brühl beobachtet in Kiev wie die junge
Generation dort versucht ihren
Lebensstil aufrecht zu erhalten trotz
ständiger luftalarme und zugleich
Solidarität mit den Soldaten an der
Front zu zeigen
die Stadt ist noch voll an diesem
Freitagabend in Kiev Kneipen Bars alles
offen das hier ist kein Club sondern das
Büro einer Hilfsorganisation repair
together organisiert regelmäßig Events
bei denen es vor allem darum geht andere
zu
unterstützen es ist cool wie eine kleine
Party aber wir machen was nützliches D
den Leuten um uns rum
hilft Paraffinkerzen für die Soldaten an
der Front sie je nach Größe brennen die
Kerzen bis zu 12 Stunden die Soldaten in
den Schützengräben können sich damit die
Hände wärmen Wäsche trocknen Essen heiß
machen es ist meist die einzige
Wärmequelle warum ist es euch wichtig
die Soldaten zu
unterstützen das ist unser Land wir sind
unseren Soldaten sehr dankbar für das
was sie tun und das hier ist wirklich
nur eine Kleinigkeit was wir machen
können um Ihnen zu
helfen
jeder in der Ukraine hat Freunde und
Verwandte die
kämpfen auch viele Männer sind an diesem
Abend da ob sie keine Angst davor haben
eingezogen zu werden fragen wir
sie ich bin bereit zur Armee zu gehen
denn wenn nicht wir unser Land
verteidigen wer sollte es dann
machen wir haben gar keine andere WL als
zuwinnen sonst sehe ich überhaup keine
Perspektive
an diesem Abend und die meisten sehen
sie in ihrer Heimat der
Ukraine ich unterstütze mein Land ich
werde es auf keinen Fall verlassen ich
bin jetzt sehr stolz auf unsere Nation
denn jetzt sind wir uns
einig der Blick auf ihr Land hat sich
seit Kriegsbeginn radikal verändert
sagen uns viele die Unterstützung für
die die die Ukraine verteidigen wird
plötzlich zur
Selbstverständlichkeit jetzt hält man
das für normal darin spürt man
Unterstützung Liebe Verständnis warum
Leute das fürinander
machen es ist die freiwillige Arbeit die
hilft mit dieser Realität
zurechtzukommen das ist wie eine Insel
der Gutherzigkeit und
Wärme helfen um sich selbst zu helfen an
diesem Freitag Abend in Kiev ist das was
zählt zwischen auch häufiger Demos von
soldatenmüttern und Frauen die sich über
zu lange Einsatzzeiten der Soldaten
beschweren in Russland gibt es durchaus
auch besorgte Mütter und Frauen aber
darüber berichten darf man in Moskau
offenkundig nicht hat in Moskau sind bei
einer Protestaktion gegen die
Rekrutierung von Soldaten für den Krieg
gegen die Ukraine mehrere Menschen
vorübergehend festgenommen worden
organisiert hatten den Protest Frauen
deren Ehemänner einberufen wurden die
Polizei hat Medien zufolge insgesamt 27
Menschen abgeführt unter ihnen auch
Journalisten die offenbar später wieder
freik
kamen Außenministerin berbock hat Israel
davor gewarnt die Militäroffensive auf
Rafa im südlichsten Teil des
gasastreifens auszuweiten berbock sagte
dem redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland jetzt
in Rafa an dem letzten und
überfülltesten Ort vorzugehen wie vom
israelischen Verteidigungsminister
angekündigt wäre einfach nicht zu
rechtfertigen in Rafa und Umgebung
sollen inzwischen mehr als 1,3 Millionen
Menschen sich
aufhalten in Nordirland hat das
Parlament nach Z Jahren politischer
Krise eine neue Regierungschefin gewählt
die schinfin Politikerin Michelle O'Neil
und damit zum ersten Mal eine
katholische Politikerin die sich für
eine Vereinigung des früheren
bürgerkriegslandes mit Irland einsetzt
oil muss aber nach dem sogenannten K
freitagsabkom mit der größten
protestantischen Partei die up zusammen
regieren die für die politische Union
mit Großbritannien
Eintritt nach Deutschland hier gab es
heute weitere bauernproteste und zwar
rund um den Frankfurter Flughafen laut
Polizei kamen Landwirte mit rund 400
Traktoren zusammen die
Flughafengesellschaft hatte Passagiere
dazu aufgerufen mehr Zeit bei der
Anreise einzuplanen die Zugänge zu den
Terminals seien aber nicht blockiert
Wesen und jetzt die Lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewehr 3 14 19 21 23 24 Superzahl 5
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdfde und im ZDF Text auf Seite
556 noch die Wetteraussichten morgen
wird es entlang der Alpen am sonnigsten
auch an den Küsten gibt es ein paar
Chancen auf Sonne sonst wiegen dichte
Wolken mit Regen bei einem frischen
Westwind werden 7 bis 13° erreicht die
weiteren Aussichten die neue Woche
startet im Süden sehr mild mit bis zu
15° und freundlich in der Mitte und im
Norden ist es eher wechselhaft und
stürmisch das war's von uns gleich
geht's mit dem Aktuellen Sportstudio
weiter gegen 0:25 Uhr gibt's dann die
nächste heute Express uns morgen wieder
auf Wiedersehen
wiedersehen
ه